all right hey we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 69
it's another glorious Sunday and we are
back at the roundtable on the Lord's Day
I'm extremely excited about our special
patreon I guess so we go get right into
it I want to introduce the Lord who is
not only a huge friend to the room
personally but it's also a fellow IT
brethren at heart this Lord is a man
strong gaming opinions hilarious twitch
dreams it is also one of our brand new
up-and-coming content creators in the
game introducing the host of the snow
though YouTube channel and twitch
affiliate streamer one of the most
vibrant personalities in the game
protector of guinea pigs were a lot the
Lord you should never leave behind the
wheel in a state of decay to supplier a
fellow New Yorker making his debut into
the realm of the Lord's my man Lord
Peter Leone how are you doing sir happy
round we go have some fun man no doubt
no doubt
and of course we got my brother co-host
with the como si we join us probably in
progress but you know we still got our
most technical gaming Lord the solo
gamer who lives for the single player
selfish experience and is also the
sastra Thomas mr. offline profile
Illuminati and Lord patreon himself my
man Lord sovereign how're you doing sir
doing fantastic man good to be here you
know had a long weekend accountably I
took a I took the forth over to a couple
days went out to uh to Washington
chilled out so you know well you were to
DC
all right what else is going on same oh
yes same old man now we're gonna we're
gonna do this up front oh right guys we
know last week we messed up a little bit
on paying the bills and giving our
shoutouts to our patreon subscribers so
don't make sure we take care of that
right about now yes sir
start off let's give a big big shout out
to all of our patreon subscribers we
can't thank you guys enough for the help
of support you guys give us on a monthly
basis absolutely greatly appreciated as
I said like everything you guys do helps
towards improving the podcast and and
the quality of the stuff that we do you
see that already uh Lord addict has
improved this mic game considerably mine
is in route as well so we're doing it in
that regard and that's thanks to you
guys so let me give a shout-out to
everybody who supports us every single
mile so gonna start out off with of
course I guess today thank you so much
appreciate and after that I gotta give a
big shout-out to Lord deathsinger thank
you so much brother Lord snail killer
aka Diego Padre thank you so that's the
man right be much appreciated Lord cat
daddy's fat stack stands brother the man
is always on the road and he always
manages to listen to us so much
appreciate it
Lord Spoonman much love for do the
googly always in hand to chat much a
pretty much the same with our brother
from the west coast lord of relevant
native oh thank you brother and of
course the other side of the realm Lord
bills still well
supporting the Lord's that's right
absolutely expect that name and man and
last but absolutely not least the man
who's always in the chat every single
Sunday great opinions always here to
support Lord Michael Lugo
much appreciated brother thank you guys
for coming out every single month and
helping us out we really appreciate it
alright so we're gonna get into these
giveaways so this month we're not doing
again giveaway it's every other month so
we're this month we'll be doing the ten
dollar giveaway the twenty dollar
giveaway and of course a t-shirt all
right let's start it off with this
t-shirt okay this random name generator
here while you talk about the to show
you should get up definitely copper bomb
giveaway so the winner of our t-shirt
for this month is Lord Michael Lugo my
god every last t-shirt we don't worry
Mike you know later on as well as the
swag increases and and the the different
types of swag that's coming down the
pipeline Oh there'll be more selection
alright alright so let's get into this
$10 gift card giveaway and the winner of
that is Lord he really supports really
appreciated and considering that his
line of work the fact that he can listen
to us all the time that's crazy
no alright so let's get into this final
give away our $20 gift
card the winner of that is Lord snail
killer thank you so much killer all you
guys have won congratulations get at me
in my DMS and with all your information
what you guys want in terms of the the
gift cards you guys know it could be
Steam PSN and Xbox Live whatever you
guys want a Nintendo eShop whatever it
may be
thank you guys again thank you to all
our patreon subscribers you guys are the
best really appreciate every little bit
that you guys you know put out every
single month and again our goal is to
keep improving and making better content
for you guys so thanks again we'll see
you next month with all of these
giveaways in addition to a digital game
giveaway but they don't thank you Lord
sovereign aka Lord patreon himself
yes Louis offset tremendous tremendous
I'll finish out these intros and of
course we have the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS game early on my bad
levels is good still in a no combat
sports was a man of his convictions
demands nothing less than that premium
experience and is to get mighty game up
Oh beloved Lord King how you doing sir
I'm doing kind of sad today I like to
give a shout-out to bloody knuckles for
bringing this to my attention
um when he told me about it
was kind of disheartened then what that
we lost a very important Lord to the
realm of entertainment because our
medium our chosen medium of
entertainment is brought all right so we
got movies and extensive video games and
it goes to literature and Steve Ditko
was very instrumental and bring a
character to us that is near and dear to
everyone's heart and that Spiderman past
really do all the super information on
the age and stuff like that but his
passing his felt so I just like you know
give a moment of silence for the creator
and writer for spider-man who has passed
know and it's kind of fitting that
Spiderman was brought back to Marvel so
he can probably see his vision realized
you know at the end before his passing
so all right so let's get on to the show
let's get into this a something at the
end when you're finished okay
no yeah UFC 226 was in the box room
saying and of course we had the main
event or do you I'm in league I want to
go to opposite way you won't lead up or
you won't go in all right cool
yeah pretty much you know first of all I
want to shout out to the hangman Dan
hooker impressive TKO victory
up-and-coming in that division
you're gonna look out for this kid man
he looks real good I like what's going
on I want to give a rest in peace
shoutout to Uriah Hall oh yeah yeah
that's not do God by self yes oh man I'm
sorry I like your eye hole but the man
peeked at the at the at the tough
knockout that was it he peaked there and
that was that
yeah my thing when Hema is the bad way
country so when he almost passed out
trying to make way so I don't I don't
think he found his footing yet he can
still come back fairly young II got bomb
blasted all shout out to a local
hospital that looked like a bigger
scarier version of him body shots and he
just put that boy out I mean but his
body just quit on him and then I want to
talk about that uh Showtime the loss is
trying to find his way he never seemed
to really be able to stop wrestlers that
was my concerns once they kind of solve
them on that with the feet cuz the boy
the boy got Taekwondo for days you know
I'm saying like he kicked brought on
yeah him but yesterday had a lot of bad
blood going into the fight she has some
is weight and got some shout out to show
you look good you know I've said it
before like I thought he was done and he
just never found his way back and this
was Showtime Pettis yeah with the
precision striking Viper and he just
comes in and when he gets that
submission on you when he get it's not
coming off in there and this is the old
Showtime Pettis WEC yeah it felt like it
you know I'm saying hopefully he gets
you know this this was maybe jumpstart
him and maybe find his way that was good
to see that was good to see the next
step we have arguably the worst
heavyweight fight in the history you are
the absolute to fraudulent dudes who
talk all this trash leading up to the
fight I got a call people out to the
carpet Derek looks at Lewis Francis in
Ghana please come to the front of
congregation now you guys are fired
fired proceeded to stare at each other
for three rounds no one throwing any
significant strikes all this like over
respect and scared at a power with Derek
losses Tom crazy and Francis was Tom
crazy by the way on
there goes my way we won by like a snore
decision I don't even know how to even
one with activities as low as both of
them was it was a swift decision on low
activity I wasn't giving them both else
yeah but this performance this was the
worst thing I've ever seen straighter I
was through less than a hundred punches
between them ridiculous shout out
forearm did for Dana white for calling
out in Ghana saying the Eagles gotten
too big and he was a training and he was
in Paris before the steep a fight and
all this way therapy like broken Miocic
steep a broke dude do don't want a fight
and it's like he's scared of everything
he skated you take that he scared the
engage you know I'm saying and Derrick
Lewis I blame because he was talking Wow
crazy before the fight hi he wanted this
fight and this that now shut up I'm now
will salute him in a sense the other
fact he said you're I don't even deserve
to be calling nobody out yeah you don't
and when you wanna check who's watching
that bad boy last night you guys you
know and all the tweaking of the main
226 Daniel Cormier versus steep a yogic
man and this was a scary I didn't know
what was gonna happen this one because
honestly it was very hard to go get
steep a coming in you know steep a has
pretty much weather the storm is beat
the best of the best and DC the oldc I
know I would have been more confident
but then coming off at a
los you know to kick to the head the
steroid kicked again extra power to the
head and then you know Stevens last when
a link on oh I couldn't
my heart said DC on my mind said Stevie
and coming into it was a good start you
know feeling each other out you don't a
feed D stymie sleep I seem to be
imposing his physicality a little bit so
I don't know
then the boxing kind of went down and
even DC you know being back up a
heavyweight kind of like the fat kid in
the part that nobody picked the clay so
he did your body structure is that way
around just it just looked at the extra
chunking I remember him saying but
before that he wasn't going trained away
like I like heavy weight so I don't know
what car do you know I'm saying like
well yo right round one y'all caught him
with a two-piece and steep face chin
shows just revealed itself really opened
up you know on the ground it was all a
it was it was very surprising you don't
say like it was like he belongs where he
looked which I know what you felt all
this I won't be honest man with you know
the young Ghana blues fight and then
going into the main event and everything
that happened in the main event it's
like I saw my beloved UFC go left right
there like literally like in the bushes
with Kings the games the king doesn't
like right in the bushes like it felt
like it turned into WWE yeah let's talk
about the elevator
alright alright so I mean my thing is
this right everything surrounding that
fight and I give props to Daniel Cormier
like Daniel if he he's won the the
Heavyweight Grand Prix yeah I think it
was a Mike force so and he his power
translates well to that weight his his
wrestling ability in his bill
is ability just to be on top of somebody
like and just wear them down translates
great to that weight mm-hmm
but you just took a guy out then took
out a dude with a lightning bolt punch
yeah multiple punches from Mangano his
last fight and to all of a sudden just
get dropped like that and put out it
just all it felt because good you know
felt scripted normally all the way back
to to Daniel falling after the after the
press coming back and this is like and
then everything that happened after the
fight with the Brock last night was
obviously with rock was there for a
reason like reason yeah I didn't like
that I didn't like that let me jump in
on that real quick or in their defense
though steep his Chin's been suss though
like he got dropped in in in the arm
over in fright yeah I've seen a couple
fights where the chin is it's just a his
technique and his strategy is he's very
good but I gotta agree with you like I
didn't like the whole you know Brock
stare and it was so good did he call DC
calls a mountain it's got come runs into
the ring why don't we watch you know
he's no I felt like Vince Russo W air
like it was totally scripted and the
thing about it is that like even my dues
like Dominick Cruz they're playing along
with a smile and laugh I'm almost done I
mean pretty much the conversation now
outside of the theatrics the
conversation right now and I want to
bring this to y'all real quick I know we
go on long conference was but um the
talk right now is DC is to go that's the
talk you know - to induce losses right
that he's been undefeated at heavyweight
yep and undefeated like
check this out booms is a bad fight for
him in terms of just body type it's a
bad fight for him like Daniel you don't
ask to reach up to him like but bones is
like I don't think bones goes up to
heavy weight and fights TV and comes out
and my concern is also will be like rock
either but yeah I can't get off flick it
off we got you I'm bout to book in the
crap out of this mom you call me the
original I'm gonna cry in the car dude I
gotta keep my cursor because when I
stole your energy and the press
conference we had the two belts he was
really filling yourself dude it was
really filling yourself but the last
time I saw you tears in your eyes you're
standing I don't like my my fighters I
don't like my fighters salt you know
yeah and you can probably say something
like oh a man can cry shut up crying
your pillow like the rest of them you
cry in your pillow like the rest of us
when nobody's watching anytime that you
able to cry in public is when it's tears
of joy
you take it like a man I spoil your
smiles and yeah you know so at this part
right here where was that part when he
kicked you in your head
we was dead oh no cuz no goats cry crap
you believe that alone anybody talk
about they represent in this tear water
bottle face I want that one do you kick
him upside his head again I put my money
on bones fresh and clean with no
caffeine face I don't like I can't
it was the best night of my life it was
the best night I had with the guy I know
everything so like for you this for you
guys right now realness in the realm of
the ILP now tell me what you want to
hear but what you need to hear so before
we get into what the Lord's are playing
I want to start off with the Lord
no video game system history that career
in IT with your fellow Lord oh haha we
finally got you started as a new content
creator so what's not know what's that
man from the beginning
give me those first gaming systems right
first gaming systems the first one that
I can remember is actually when I was a
little baby sitting on my cousin's
playing in television little tank games
those were classics and then when I got
older I found out my parents had an
old-school Atari like original Atari in
the closet I pulled that bad boy yeah
hooked it up and it worked and I was
like you've got it it was good it was
great but man between going through all
that we had the Nintendo which I got for
my grandparents it was awesome
and then we got our Sega Genesis from my
aunt who my parents were so angry my
parents were like very anti do not want
the kids to play video games we only got
to play Friday Saturday and Sunday that
long until we were in high school like I
had to fight when I was like a CEO and
I'm cuter it's like I finally get my
view against all all week long
that was me that long cause that was me
once my parents left though it was just
like where the head games
where's Ninja Turtles like it's the
devil like you're not supposed to do it
like what was it like oh it was it
wasn't that way they just didn't want us
to consume ourselves hence we played
non-stop now as adults try to catch up
on times that you fight it now I got my
xbox want to get my ps4 gotta get that
bad boy but yeah when that now I don't
have a switch but
[Laughter]
you'll get their PlayStation got some
great games on it the switches got some
great games on I want to get to them
eventually and right now I'm sitting
mostly on the PC I got so many games on
the PC I can tell you know saying you
know art history and stuff like that
just wanting to like when did you kind
of transition into the PC gaming realm I
said you kind of hard but I'll see to
the cooker to the crowd never when it
listening you know you actually the
first person I tested cross play with
disdain and I warned you I was like dude
a drive and I like it me okay I know
wanting it to stop getting stuff broken
oh my god yeah I started transitioning
into PC when I started playing Warcraft
and back back in was it oh six just
wanna know one Wow started coming out
I started playing PC more and more and
more and I just it's easier for me to
play games now first-person shooters I
feel like so it's like it takes more
skill when are you planning on a PC than
Xbox or Playstation no offense to you
guys but it's just it's something that I
just I just gotten used to and I enjoyed
one love and cross play though now
because of being able to play with you
know like what we did with say decay and
with other things coming out
I can't I think that's the cool part you
know then people don't give myself
enough credit for just that whole
merging those worlds together I will say
I am I I my first my first next-gen
console if you will because I skipped
Super Nintendo and I originally bought a
Playstation I forgot about this I
painted
classrooms with my mom for two days and
the amount of money I got I had it in my
hands and my mom's like what do you want
dude that money I'm like bring me to
Toys R Us a Playstation and she was like
what is that what I don't want to know I
was in color not too many gaps I'm
impressed
so um obviously we know that IT career
button you know saying and of course you
know your boy Lord cognate oh yeah yeah
cross paths with Lord snow though so
briefly about your IT background you
know is that did that also influence you
as far as the gaming for me I worked I
actually wanted to be a software
programmer Lundin on being on this
island of you know New York is very
minimal job so I ended up going for the
the networking path in addition to the
software path I just grabbed just
grabbed a job that I could find and I
just cruised with it and that's when you
and I met up and I will remember knowing
your passion for games when you were
like I'll Drive all the way to New York
to pick up you know I'm like legend of
the gamertag man totally over that way
yeah but dude that man Tony Oh classic
body by somebody called me and totally
was upset I ran around just knifing
everyone dr. dad sit for the whole match
you'd be like why am i dead and that
just says may Antonio nice
[Laughter]
we wasn't ready to get mad cuz of the
name is like we're getting killed by
[Music]
[Laughter]
cool about that Cruz Louis knows that we
had a ton of gamers that we worked even
even like a ball shoutout to oh sorry oh
Roman Roman Roman we as so it was a good
group of IT guys and we had so many
hardcore gamers as part of that group
so we just laugh and bug out it was just
family man those it was a good times we
do that we do the conversion down in
some some was called in Indiana yes look
over a gene and I see me got a
controller in his hand he's playing
Mortal Kombat whoa presentation and I
was just like what are you doing all old
team you're saying like that's the crew
right there they absolutely don't know
down so we got there going on there
finally the inspiration did hope you
would got you started to finally jump
into the content you don't come to I'm
sorry guy no no just like the whole
YouTube channel on the twitch streaming
like what kind of finally said you know
what I'm gonna do this thing what would
lost now know what you just saw so I saw
a lot of a lot of my friends ending up
doing a lot of twitch streaming and a
lot of content creation and and I
thought to myself I was like well I love
doing that stuff I love giving back to
to my friends community like like I do
for you guys and I was like wow how else
better to do that than to start doing
this so I usually end up taking usually
parts of throughout the whole entire
year either my subs or my donations and
you know all them all the money you know
I take and I give it back so I try to
give back a lot of games I'm talking a
lot of games don't like maybe one or two
a month to to my
people that come to my channels I try to
do at least one or two months out of the
year all of the donations all
subscription money everything that I get
might give them to it to some some type
of charity Wow yeah yeah so like I'm
gonna be doing I'm actually in the
process of working on doing a charity
for a guinea pig donation in January of
next year I'm working on doing in
November I usually do go to a charity
for disabled children so the money I get
I give to that so that's that's what I
that's why I wanted to start doing this
not just for myself you know I have my
job um I have my amazing wife you know I
have those things that are they don't
ground me you know I want to help others
and there are some people that are
playing games it they just they don't
have the money to do it
you know if they want if they're willing
to you know put the time and to hang out
with me playing games like I'm talking
you when we went to PAX East
I bought a handful of games when I was
there because those things are all
discounted so I can you start giving
away for people and then you know and
it's it's great to have that community
come back to sabes a little later
the first was salute to the Lord's now
they're doing the Lord's work though you
know I'm saying like that's a positive
role and we really want to support that
and actually elevate that kind of talk
yeah you know because a lot of people
are not doing that they're not giving
back they're not even thinking about
others so that's super positive man I'm
proud of you my senior getting out you
start out there quarter companies and
cut your bad driving screen when you
included me but now shout out do you
really out here doing it man and I'm
really really positive
absolutely so of course we gotta ask all
the guests the final question top five
video games or franchises oh oh
let's go so I I was I was ready for this
cuz I know that you guys do this to
everybody so I made sure I wrote them
down
let's go so first of all Final Fantasy
series that RPG and everything from from
the start
what they're doing now with file fancy
15 even the content that they're doing
with mmo's with what they're doing with
their file Fantasy 14 I just it's
amazing I love it it's it's great uh
Monster Hunter I never really was into
the Monster Hunter genre but where I
play it once it came out where Xbox I
picked that bad boy up and I'm just like
this is good this is this is fun
this is it's never scale yeah man we got
two Lords before you had that vouch in
Lord Eric's and bogey that they monster
hunted to the death Lord zero as well
yeah when it launched and that flares
didn't work that was the most
aggravating thing because I would just
get my butt kicked
nobody anything Mario related remember
Mario touches is gold I don't know what
it is that hold that old franchise I
can't even say it's just Mario Mario and
Link those thing so we got we got we got
we got low Final Fantasy series 80 merry
okay anything really anything Mario and
even rabbits so the series is for no I
I'm not counting Zelda because I put
them together I always felt like Mario
and light and you know that Zelda series
are always together now you got a tough
choice
you gotta make you want you at the
lowest round table you either you gotta
make a choice or you gotta add it to the
list
no all right well we'll have to take off
link them because creed I I can't tell
you I've played every single one of them
like over and over and over again i I
went opening day not even opening day
the day before opening day to see the
movie like my wife my father picked up
doughnuts for tonight I that that's the
thing that movie the way that they did
it it was I didn't like how they did it
or it's just those Assassin's Creed
elements that they placed in there which
kind of was enjoyable I like the whole
winning we're in the Animas a post
outside then it was like the grill games
just stay there spelling my belief um
this whole ancient time that's a strong
500 coming for faith that's um I like
that like that no doubt fantastic
history getting into the game I like
that I like what's going on so we go get
into what the Lord's have been playing
this week Lord saw what have you been
playing sweetness I haven't really been
home man so just more switch Mario
Tennis luminous finally beat that damn
boss you know the Mario's Menace and the
thing is like
you just you keep getting XP no matter
if you win or lose right so by the time
on him I was so Opie I was like level 30
by the time I beat him so the rest of
the rest of the story was easy
so pretty much padam lee stress which
[Applause]
you see me know it was so try hard this
week i was all my yo i was hanging out
with shout out the Chris and start out
the Captain America because those
brothers was running me through the
ringer I mean Lord monkey Lord monkey I
understand you as a casualty of war this
week mm-hmm I did get a chance to play
with you at some point in time but these
brothers see me on I don't know if my
team but listen the moonshine on the
Playstations rear behind I play God of
War okay I play got a wall so I had to
boot up the piss station Oh
upload/download
right so you know I don't play all the
time yo cheat on me I'm going there baby
I picked up the controller and the
controller was dead so I had to
and put it inside my own portable
battery charger but I say you know what
let me take a picture of this and throw
it on Twitter oh well that went viral
do it they've been hit me up on that um
and I think that was a mistake but
because they think that is a great idea
having a dead controller hooray like you
can't throw batteries in or change out
or it's just just the mentality um but
do what sheep will do anyway so I'm
playing God of War and I realized why I
really love the game the primary colors
the mothering colors on the game makes
it so vibrant it is so sharp because I'm
playing on a pro and it is so sharp and
the colors are pop so well that said
damn this game really really looks good
like it really looks good and it's from
a color standpoint to the game art
direction to the cinematics it's
fantastic I say this to tell you
spider-man does that into bushes okay no
no trust me when I'm telling you that I
love that game like I really love God a
war it's a really good game like I get a
feeling of a sense of accomplishment
even when I booted up to be honest with
you I really loved it it was really good
game but and I say that to say this
system has potentially two of the best
games our generation that's gonna be on
a system and that's the must own so
anybody has a Playstation please have it
and if you have that extra cash and you
have Xbox when you're looking at uh you
want to rent it rent those two games in
that system and try it you need to try
it this generation so I just went back
to the god one I just had to say that
it's fantastic that's cool man get the
cheat you fired it up and you blew up my
Twitter notification meet you cuz you
crazy and I'm like why's everybody going
at him and why's everybody going at the
place it was just too much control of
beef for Molly for me to take you
it got crazy when Cole Eastwood jumped
in yeah I know we had different
proportions Lord King man she's been
really destiny to crucible for me all
day
there's been a that triple Valor weekend
so I've been rock out that one shouts um
Charla Fonzarelli mankai box Lou and
Neil please getting it in just wrecking
fools we put some posts up on Twitter on
a podcast you know we had so much fun
killing it you know I'm saying I got to
mythic level hopefully we can prestige
that valor you know I'm saying I'm
definitely having a lot of fun with the
crucible it's really cool with a team
and then other than that all has just
been when I'm not home there's been a
switch I still stuck or I'm I mean on
banner saga
I'm actually really getting into it man
I'm really understanding strategies love
and banner saga and I just want to
complete that so I can jump into part
two so I'm gonna be on banner saga for
WoW so let's get it to this poll last
week's III eat recap all the results are
in and the people have spoken now that
the dust from e3 2018 has settled which
of these titles is your most anticipated
game to purchase the winner at 49% in
convincing fashion in a four way aisle
people was the cyberpunk 2077 group yes
sir cyberpunk is he out here coming in
at second place at 24% was the last of
us to group and coming in at a super
shallow third place at 15% I should be
ashamed the also with the gears pop and
gears tactics 1e3 group and depressingly
coming in at last at 12
Shane Shane
so what are the lowest think about lost
I'll go man what do you think about this
the most anticipated game
I I came and tell ya you know what
cyberpunk was when we saw that because
when it popped up it it's just the
feeling you just get from that game is
very different from the other ones so
it's you know it's gonna propel it more
so than the others so I think that it's
gonna really pull itself together more
so when we see more of the gaming
content yeah absolutely so I think
that's what's gonna be holding it yeah
I'm holding the forefront yeah
absolutely I got from good sources that
are you know shout the hip-hop shout out
to UM we tried very hard even trying to
finesse which I mean they pretty much
had Eric's we had all as we got in their
arm a shock she shot up juggling them in
form or foundry those guys to the
foundry those guys they got it and every
person that we talked to said that not
only was it by far the best thing at e3
that it looked so next-gen that it's
doing things that current platforms are
not capable of so yeah unless they ever
the case like that due to lack of try
he's right it was just it's impregnable
can that penetrate that's why the
shadows dudes over there and um yeah man
so that was the poll and obviously we
gonna get into looking for actually a
new poll at the end of the show so it's
getting to these topics remember I like
to talk about Lord King nation
what's going on all right well first of
all I like to give credit to Lord from
the
Randall Thor Lord dealer shout out the
Lord dealer gave me friend of the room
they both did expose days on this whole
topic but I'm gonna tape it taking in a
different direction
you're the post and for Call of Duty and
it's for the narrative of the next
generation called a duty on next
generation series um and the date that
the game's supposed to come out because
that means if they're doing the story
aspect of it and they trying to pull a
story together and the accident for
writers for the story that means that
the game is far along in its process as
far as assets go and graphics design and
direction and they needed to be pulled
together with a narrative okay that
means that the narrative is being formed
around either a first-person story or
could be how are we gonna get this story
wrapped around some attics sense but
it's loose ends so the game is supposed
to come out of 2019 yes now in saying
that that would mean and it's for next
generation systems that these next
generation systems should be out holiday
of 2019 so it's not just um when I get
multiple systems I'm thinking more than
just a Playstation and Nintendo
I mean I'm placing a Microsoft I'm
thinking Nintendo as well because it
could say I don't know the wording of it
seemed to implicate more than just them
- hey where you going oh I'm sorry
if you want to you know I want to know
if it's okay first I want to know if
it's too soon do you guys think it's too
soon for the next-gen to pop out being
that we just had a X our PlayStation Pro
is just probably hitting its stride
because ghosts of Tsushima from what I
hear from digital foundry was running on
a Playstation pro right so
in knowing this information do we feel
it they're rushing it good question good
question
let me I'm gonna set up or do we believe
that it's coming out and good question
I'm gonna set it up for Salah to also
just a privacy try so shout out again
shout to branch out a deal and shout
everyone to Charlie and tell these guys
that I posted a story and um yeah so
pretty much there's a job listing right
there's a it's a narrative scripter and
infinity war right so we know for pretty
much for almost for the fact that the
next Call of Duty is actually gonna have
a single-player campaign traditional
because we know obviously the upcoming
one was it black ops for they've ditched
that so it looks like they're going back
to it but like war kings said then it's
saying for multiple next-gen platforms
that's what the listing said so like the
next round like plural right in
development so it's now the what do you
think about that and like to Lord Kings
question like if is it too soon if true
like where's your head at with this so
so this is something that I've actually
had multiple discussions with other
people about because me personally I
think the Xbox S and a P escrow it's
literally Xbox and PlayStation saying
okay we have these really good games
that are coming out but we need to put a
little more power in them so let's just
read let's just take this apart re put
it back together
just throw a name on it and throw it out
there like it's just like it's the same
exact console just updated information
like just updated Hardware just like
everyone does with the computer you know
when you're playing a game and they
decide all right well we're gonna we're
gonna put this other game out but we
won't have better graphics on it so what
are you gonna do you're gonna buy a
whole new computer no you're just gonna
get a new video card and you're just
gonna drop it in so right I feel like
that's what the ps4 ps4 Pro and the Xbox
x-bar that's always how I felt
I feel like that 20:19 for this next-gen
is a little too soon it's just a little
too soon
I would think that
20 would probably be the perfect
stepping stone for them mm-hmm because
because number one you'd expect them to
at least have a little bit of rumblings
yes it III just a little bit yes there
was something that they were thinking of
yes but I don't I don't think it's ready
for it I feel you man this is good man
Lord saw how much input man we haven't
got a chance to to kick it on this
subject I mean III would agree with Lois
now though like for me 2019 if we see
anything in 2019 I would think it would
be PlayStation and not Xbox just because
the pro came out in 2016 so what are you
yeah before you and that that makes
sense two years between console releases
I don't care how much of an upgrade it
is how much it's it's too it's too small
a time it's too short a time three years
okay I'm willing to deal with that so
with that said I 2019 to me does not it
just feels too soon regardless like
again like pro maybe a new Playstation
but I see it more at the beginnings of
2020 towards the end of 2020 so this can
have some truth to it in that these
games come out so this new infinity war
game should be coming out holiday next
year right right and you won't get
another infinity or you won't get
another Hall Duty game to the holiday
2020 so if let's say let's say these new
consoles launched in the first quarter
of 2020 instead of fourth quarter like
they usually do right you know switches
shown that you can launch a console
whenever during the course of the year
and and you're gonna be successful
especially the next PlayStation or next
Xbox they're gonna sell regardless to
what so I can see this quote you know
kind of in quotations being a next-gen
game and if those consoles launch in
that time period before the next Call of
Duty after Infinity Ward's game because
you do have a few months in between
there where this this this game could be
across console game mom so that that's
the only way it can technically happen
but for me honestly I just full-out
I think 2020 for these next consoles I
really
let me jump in I mean this is
interesting and I want to shout out a
couple Lord to shout the Lord a fund's
really shout to Lorraine we actually had
some good conversations offline about
this and um I think I felt like I don't
Fonz is ready let's go and shout out the
funds because he really riding you know
waving his flag hi about 2019 for the
longest and I thought it was crazy
so shot the fun you know it's one of
those things right now it's like you
know his argument which is which is a
decent honest ano I'm ready for it right
now I want the new hardware I want the
next level of power the CP user you know
kind of underbaked and you know that we
need to see 60 frames on everything I
get it you know my whole thing is just
like again from an old-school
perspective right it just feels like yo
we kind of hit not stride like like I
guess consume like I'm not ready because
also my backlog is insane to so that may
be a couple but on yeah I mean at that
any day look this cauldron looks look
League seems real you know narrative is
story you know they're working on that
aspect my gut still says if anything
revealed at 2019 come this a three and
in 2020 is to set up the rollout but I
will say this and I want to bring this
to the Lord's this is a great topic is
that what if the 2019 thing is real
let's just say we're wrong and we you
know it's 20 is 2019 right
who do you think comes out first come
out the same time because the argument
hours I'll get to you the argument I was
hearing was that post and that
PlayStation will come our first big sale
on the window and if I can't have
Microsoft out there with X you know and
take the power tower of back so I'm just
curious to see if it's both or which one
if it's only one so you say can you all
the way Microsoft with it the reason why
I say that is because Phil works so hard
to yanked a narrative the way that he
won't concede it
know the mentality of the individual
that's in charge at this point in time
is he takes chess pieces off the board
mm-hmm so in removing these chess pieces
they're already in place to have their
how can I say it um the development
houses and their studios putting these
games in place for that said launched
and in talking to these guys at this III
they explained to me that next III would
be epic and they use these words not two
individuals said the same exact thing to
higher-ups and they said don't mess next
year it's going to be epic right now I
know they know because they dealing with
the same chip developers when about
their chips will be ready and they can
get a casing and you know from designs
and the system can get to launch right
so you don't think that they're fighting
in the same position they would seem to
be price-wise outer mark power-wise out
of mark because they lost this
generation from the missteps in the
beginning I don't think they make those
same missteps PlayStation will not be
able to get a foothold like that that's
my opinion of it I think they do launch
though in the same month probably a week
apart yeah this is this is interesting
too and I'm bringing back it's not in a
minute well um like I I hate you I hate
and I just think like I want to know if
Mark like I say cuz everybody is under
the impression dad like you know these
guys as far as so much let's focus on
something like from from from what
respect that of like you know they've
been the longest without a new system
between the two right so because the pro
came out when a pro came out and they've
been kind of known to break protocol
like just look at the pro like really no
one expected that you know I'm saying so
I'm just curious if Sony would jump out
the window with it first
and obviously I do agree with King like
I don't I think that these are guys are
in the same circle the same chip says
like you know saying like if Microsoft
got wind of it
you don't say Microsoft might drop at
the same time as well your subtle what
do you think again coming from the
perspective if it's 2019 what do you
think drops first or what what do you
think happens if for me I I would hope
that Microsoft comes out first because
they have the most to lose no you don't
have a good bank that's what I've been
saying no if if you if you look back now
I'm talking the original Xbox Xbox 360
they had so many games that will
exclusively
want them the Xbox one now I it pains
for me to say because I love Microsoft
I'm not and and I very rarely even touch
it because they don't have those
exclusive games anymore when I'm gonna
say this name of this game and you guys
are gonna trash me for it when
scalebound came out and they were
talking about it in III what was that
last year or two years ago I was like oh
cool they got an exclusive that looks
really good and now I'm saying to myself
[Laughter]
now I'm saying to myself I want to get a
PlayStation 4 I want to play Detroit I
want to play play oh my god horizon zero
dawn I want those games to play when I
can't see that about Microsoft so they
need to step it up right and those and I
don't want I don't want to talk too much
because of the other two other
discussions we have yeah but they have
the backings now that they need time for
those companies now
lucky tales - I want you to die back to
shrooms which we don't we all and I
think I'd rather do this and that we
don't think it's 2019 but if it is
hypothetically but you could have gotten
what you think happens I think yeah I
think Microsoft has to come out first up
the problem with that is like lost Aldo
said I don't think any of these games
that they in these companies that they
just recently purchased has anything
ready by 2019
I don't think lo infinite is ready by
2019 so that means to me they're
launching we're launching with gears
right ready either that would be great I
don't you know they they haven't
indicated how long they've been working
on favor right right so we don't know
but I think to me that's all 20/20 like
you can't give those games three years
like you want to bring back franchises
reinvigorate franchise I'm looking at
you know four years minimum for these
games right so then you look at
PlayStation right everybody
launched in that same window talking
about then we're talking about and if
you're looking at cross-platform games
right we're gonna play a PlayStation
launching with the Last of Us well go so
sushi what else
stranding maybe maybe bro yeah dad dad
that's a very that's why I want to jump
in on this because at the end of the day
listen I'm not saying it's gonna happen
but I could see so I don't he's been
Paley this generation let's keep it true
he is very very aggressive they don't
let's keep it real they don't like the
power narrative being taken away so
right let's also be real Microsoft
really not ready for 2019 right just
what a standpoint they just got this
these games need to bake right they
might I mean even if they drop a system
in 2019 to coincide which I think would
be still smart to kind of offset it cuz
you can't have the market leader then
drop another year before their new
platform or their new system and you're
not out there and I'm saying cuz to me
that's just continued domination in my
opinion but at the end of the day it's
like okay if Sony's out there they could
afford to do it like like Saab said
they've got games that they can say hey
this is forward compatible boom and I
don't think listen we said we okay the
reason why I think they could do it is
think about the pro nobody wanted to pro
nobody asked for the pro let's be real
it kinda came out of nowhere on their
own time they like this what we're doing
this is a mid gen refresh yada yada yada
and I'm like why are we doing this and
they kind of thing and then oh spec star
they're not forward-thinking
do you understand like well they're not
backward thinking right don't think they
don't care about you guys before 90
million that helps bono y'all in the
bushes but that was family compatible
with the regular PlayStation though
right I don't think this PlayStation 5
is gonna do that on the PlayStation 4
like it's not gonna be you're gonna have
to purchase a PlayStation 5 library like
you're gonna have to get out or lay down
Microsoft will probably be hampered in
the fact that they're gonna have to
cater to the old dudes yeah like as we
what it was the obvious conversation
right now we can't stand the fact that
the X is
being maximized down with the OG xbox is
holding us back stupid argument that's
an games has been scalable forever but
you know what
win the game like okay and I can tell
and this is this is why the argument has
merit because we can tell somebody
that's a choice you have options to xbox
right that's your choice I got totally
King right there but it's true I'm
saying I'm not questioning anybody's
situation but I'm just you know who well
have you rockin in that game with a bass
Xbox and you're playing people would X
this is gonna be vastly different it is
like but it's just you mean to tell me
that they should sell the ODE the Xbox
with a disclaimer you are a theory of
your gameplay should not matter if you
have an old xbox or a new Xbox if you're
landing here should be landing that's
what a joke yeah but like I mean they're
but they're like I say the power
difference who they're matters like
just really matters it's the reality of
it like you can try to you can talk
about like this unified ecosystem that's
great and the backwards compatibility in
the for compatibility I love that stuff
but the fact of the matter is when it
comes to jump in to talk about your
you're cutting yourself from a year of
being able to drop the price on that
machine to like if you come out 2020
they they don't cuz they're the ones
that could get away with selling you a
$500 machine this is so interesting and
I thought this Call of Duty League
really got the ball rolling I know yeah
I don't want to hear this I know look
but I'm telling you Sony if 2019 is true
I think I see the great games that they
have coming down the pike round and
collector all we hear
the studios have been picked up but we
don't see those no light no get exactly
hey and at the end of the game we all
thought us this is another TV again we
could all be wrong but another to leave
to me is the strange preparation of
their conference this year we all felt
that conference was less the games are
great but it was kind of like this is
all you're getting this is always
showing nothing else right right so to
me and that crowd different like out of
nowhere like to be they nest in
eternally I just put myself at so deeper
saying hey we're already getting up we
gotta get them you mean they took the
power down we gotta get them so we go
holy [ __ ] all punch man much respect man
I saw a guy right there look monkey
punch so um yeah I just think that maybe
they're like hey we gotta go for more
next generation and really you know
again not like they had completely
losing but again because of that
aggressive nature of showing that that
little bit of pettiness whenever
Microsoft's up and let's be real like
since e3 Microsoft up just from the
public perception right Microsoft is
ugly would you agree to us know like do
you think like um Sony's mentality could
they could adapt them and talented like
this oh no this is footage it could've
I'm not I'm not really couldn't tell you
you know but I think that maybe you know
they're anticipating is we could stick
this game out we could tell people it's
coming out in November yeah and hope
that these next-gen consoles are like oh
we're not ready at 2019 and then push
back mmm what are they gonna say what is
what is what are they Treyarch now what
are they going to do yeah I can't I keep
track of them otherwise like seongsan
fiddling wars and what's infinite or
whatever it was but they could be like
well what are we gonna be we don't have
a console to give it to you on hmm
there's gonna be a chest I can't wait
see I just think plays out man Sony pull
a Cobra
all right and when I'm telling you this
Roman Colby scored that 80 points mm-hmm
he didn't play the fourth quarter
yes all right so what he what Sony did
was they balled out hard on you and then
III came and it was like we already got
this in the bag we don't need to go out
there and finish doing this just save
this up for the next game yeah and I
feel that they taking those games and
then taking them back and they're like
yo we don't have to waste no money and
leave it all those guys to show these
stuff
next year we're gonna come out the door
we're gonna blow the wall Sheila said he
said we still have some ps4 games we
haven't talked about I doubt they're
very big games but they still have Paris
games week they still have that is true
they have TGS and they have the effects
that is true we're gonna get something
we're gonna get serviced let's move our
fantastic topic Lord King if you good
with that
no doubt no doubt and now let's get into
our Lord addicts topic hopefully the
Lord will join us in progress he had a
great time it and um omitsu they've got
an article out right now and um they
talked about a guest that infamous field
trip to Japan and and the word on the
street obviously we know that the new
Xbox the code name is Scarlett and I'm
saying we're going from Scorpio to
Scarlett as CEO and um you know pretty
much did they say that the next
generation of got Xbox consoles you know
is going to have belapur influences and
again it's come straight from the
magazine Famitsu get it from them he
said he didn't name any specific
companies that I provide the input for
the the next Xbox but he said they're
Microsoft ask Japanese devs what kind of
innovations they want to see in the
industry that can be incorporated in the
new system I was we know we traveled out
there we know that that Japan you know
they do not have much footing out there
and they're trying to get things poppin
so I'm gonna bring this to the Lord's
laurels now though like what do you
think about this announcement if you're
hearing that the next Xbox could have on
Japanese developer influence they need
it as much influence as possible to walk
into that market
they very much don't really have that
much of a presence so the only way that
they're gonna get some type of presence
there is to go to the presence talk to
the people that are there talking to the
developers talk to the people and figure
out what they're looking for and then
what they can end up doing is starting
to produce some type of content and for
them to get it so so your thought
process is regardless to whatever
happens this is still a great move on
their part to try to yeah okay so I like
hit the grips like the xbox three team
in Japan it's basic its basic market
research you know and you are trying to
go into a market that you are not doing
welding right go there you learn what
you need and then you reduce that need
yeah basic market research know what
fail works at mysterious ways lure solve
what do you think about this man I feel
like it's it feels like it's PR speak to
be honest with you oh yeah it feels like
like honestly do you think they in pass
consoles they didn't consult with
Japanese developers to see what they
want mobile but again like Japanese
Japanese developers Western developers
like you know say like they want the
same things in terms of power and like
accessibility in in in terms of you know
being able to create games more easily
right
so I think that's a foregone conclusion
that they're asking these people but I
think the PR stuff helps because again
it just gives the impression to the
outside observer that they care the old
man they're making a real push into
Japan they want to be sure that they're
letting people know that listen man
we're trying our hardest to get these
Japanese devs on board we're trying to
get you know you just trying to get that
that mindshare so that people know hey
man like you can come to xbox of
Japanese stuff so I think it makes sense
to say that but I think that's always
been a foregone conclusion like you know
if you if you didn't get input from
Japanese devs like after the odx box
like we would have had another Duke like
nothing like this the things that to me
it's just a foregone conclusion like is
it good to talk about it absolutely
absolutely
put it out there but I think it's
something that we're doing regardless I
feel sorry I disagree I mean think about
I understand I'm not having the greatest
relationships were like the like harder
core Japanese developers like the from
like they need to ferment those
relationships but they have
relationships with you know Arc System
Works with Capcom with you know you know
with Square Enix like they have
relationships already with it so it
these are people they're already talking
to gosh okay so you still think it's
finesse you still think this is
marketing its marketing I mean yes did
they probably have need to have more
conversations with these other
developers that you always see them you
know dropping exclusives on Sony's
platform yes they need to have those
conversations there's something that
we're doing anyway shelter chat channel
fire right now they say it imagine Don
Mattrick til going over there's a xbox
move all in with Xbox blu-ray players
even when they tried to do it
respectfully right and they didn't quite
understand the culture over there like
right Bill Gates went over there and he
got laughed out of a room like the same
famous blackly talking about like listen
bad like we were kind of babe in the
woods who were lost in the dark we
didn't really know how to approach it
properly and that probably cost us right
so you know this is one of those things
I think Phil is the perfect guy to go
over there and be like listen man we're
smoothing this over what do you guys
need is that perfect know what King do
you think man you think about my thing
is this is will you Peter more situation
you jump up in in you just buy crap you
just swing around that purse something
um stop chasing the pretty girl that
don't want you
hunker down in the places that would
show presents they don't go over there
go talk to them don't say nothing to
them
make them get out make them bend that
knee so what you do is you fortify your
position in places that want you
actually there you actually go and you
poach them you got enough money go and
post them go over there by Studios get
them get the best Japanese studios
that's up for grabs you know what do you
do
booze they stopped and dropped a stock
and purchase them when they fall on the
floor
then you grab them and you make them
make gains for you in that blue dragon
you get those miss Walker games just you
got just development houses take care of
that stuff over there and just drop the
bag baby
that's me with the bag if you build it
they will come
don't chase them you go and you worried
about losing Europe that was huge how
can you lose over it you go and you take
that back away from Sony you get those
places see what you didn't notice in
this generation Sony launched all over
the place yeah
Microsoft launched them probably three
places agree they Sony launched in 13
places small you have to launch and make
sure that you hit all these places over
here to hell with the person that the
people that aren't buying your products
you're not wanted Americans are not and
I'm gonna tell you this we're not wanted
there we did some horrendous stuff to
them and they not gonna forget so I
don't care about that part
leave that there let them figure it out
like yo this system is selling when your
the system market leader
they will make games for you know simple
listen man I mean this is interesting
I've been I'm be honest when I bought
this to my 10 I think this is important
I know we're solvers say I know ways
coming you know that I feel you but I
think it's different only from the
perspective of I got more confidence in
Phil doing that kind of work you know
saying I've more confidence and Phil
establishing relationships and let's be
real I mean some small from
of that labor was the Microsoft press
conference you know saying like we saw
the most Japanese games on that stage in
a long time
jump force that will make right things
that people were like ad that's not
coming to the Xbox platform you ever say
any and during his tenure let's be real
like in the automata is you know I'm
saying we're seeing stuff come to the
platform you get what I'm saying smell
though like do you starting to see you
know more of an influence and I think
that's I have to think that's attributed
to feel because prior to that you know
I'm saying
when was the dawn era you know I'm
saying we weren't seeing that and last
time I do remember seeing it was like
Lord King said we're doing the Peter
Moore Peter Moore would go over there
they spend the money we must have this
game this must be on the Xbox platform
back the truck up whatever we got to do
and those are the days what's called me
that now owns the Clippers that was on
Xbox soft and what's his name Paul you
know I'm totally oh yeah I forget his
name right now I'm calling them ball
alright good segue bear this is your
topic man we have a lot of fun with it
and how's your levels man your mics good
can you hear me fine yeah medics in a
building bro that's will stuff that we
at you topic I'm saying it's a good
thing you know as far as Japanese
developers you know supposedly having
influence on the next Xbox warp Scarlett
myself console what do you think this is
your top and what do you feel about this
day I feel like if if they don't do this
and they don't really I think this isn't
really about you know making the next
system customized for the for the
platform for the developers and
publishers of you know Forex studios I
think it's making them feel special that
they have that input in it so so so when
it comes to you know making games
they're like well we help make the Xbox
so might as well put it over there too
question the pretty girl at the office
when she goes past your desk and you say
good morning Silvia do you really think
she cares that you say hello nice dress
do you really think she gives no he just
says this guy's bothering me he knows I
don't want them just keeps walking all
right so what happens when you don't pay
her doubt that mine man you just don't
care anymore to see you doing a thing
now she's curious about now she want to
know
good morning Arliss I'm saying we don't
pursue something and you let that
something pursue you when you become
greater than their thoughts and they
have to be curious about you that's when
you infantry so the whole getting
attention by not giving attention that's
where this works whoa I feel like there
was a time where they weren't trying to
get that Japanese well I mean look this
is the reason we do our stuff way near
at large talking to them about input
into the hardware right right okay
software of course yes you have to have
these conversations with these people
there's otherwise you don't have these
relations if you're not getting these
games ever hardware to me interview
developing hardware over a series of
years you're gonna talk to these people
at some point like what do you want to
see that's what I said to me saying it
is good but to me it's something that
was already happening and like it like
addicts said like if you make them feel
like they have input in it and it gives
it hopefully creates a better
relationship with you like oh man I
asked you about this and and then that
features in the system and you know that
that's that's important that's something
to get people on board
with you so let's let's be real here as
of right now we need the Xbox brand
needs that the Japanese Todd was more
than the Japanese tiles need facts
look at look at last year the reason
last year was so devastating to the
brand is because they didn't have those
Japanese games mm-hmm a lot of those
stuff was exclusive that's what I was
saying I said you've literally jumped in
on my on my point because I was like you
know I felt the influence of Phil is
already starting to plant the seeds over
there because look at this compress calm
just a most Japanese games we've seen on
the market off stage and I'm saying
we're starting to see those titles
starting to come over the nears and all
that other stuff that were you know that
PlayStation exclusive they actually now
coming over I think that's good stuff
man
I mean guys editing out that was like
one of the nights her rooks that was the
the Saudi had they had pretty much go to
exclusives that that they didn't have to
do anything for fact fact real quick so
not the lost super Jeep Jason would have
on Lord King David I love my shirt bro
good-looking I got my boys at work
looking where can I get one of those so
look at lost now that we got our motto
in here and I want to see where this
goes hopefully it's not what sauce you
know corporate feed you you know at the
end of the day I do like the fact that
at least they're approaching them with
the new hardware and say no way just
working it might be corporate speak but
they'll gave a a guideline Phil gave a
mat and let Phil for free but she lied
about anything on that I hope you guys
understand that I think it's happening i
Balkan yeah no I don't want nothing it's
not happening yes no no no no not at all
I think it's happening it's just that if
they're saying it because it sounds good
to say it but I think it was a foregone
conclusion
anyway it was happening goodness Koch's
does a lot of it gamers feel that
they've that's
so that is an avenue that hasn't been
pursued that they've left that alone
they haven't done what they needed to do
in Japan so you had to say absolutely
but I think it's happening I think you
look at Nier automata look how good
that's doing on Xbox absolutely
absolutely man this is interesting good
stuff any laws got anything left to say
on this or we could move on to the next
topic all right so it is me I don't like
the Attic so Nintendo is in the news and
right now there's a lot of panic going
on by the investment investors right now
and um you know but at the same time you
know shout out to cortessi from Forbes
he's got some articles aren't they're
not recently the Nintendo stock has been
dropping slowly sliding downward you
know a pace of decline has been
accelerating drops as much as 5% in a
single day in total shares are down
about 34 percent since March let me go
you know obviously we had the recent
direct and apparently post direct that's
when the stock started just like
so yes so basically you know as ty
Segall avoid taxi shout I gotta get on a
show you gotta hit me up we gotta get
your show and yeah pretty much you know
he's basically saying that you know the
dishes did skyrocket when our goal was a
hit but at the end of the day you know I
blessed because of the correct me if I'm
wrong at I believe odd and dissolve but
there is some type of part ownership
Nintendo has over the Pokemon yeah they
don't come I know if they actually don't
own pokemon like right clearly
completely but they do have some type of
share so the vibe the energy is saying
it look you know yeah you guys got the
Pokemon but I didn't say you kind of
have part in that and the vibe is you
know since the wreck it's been down so I
wanted to bring this to the law as an
obviously not addicts here so uh let's
get you those like is this cause for
concern is this overblown Lord addicts
the floor is yours no it's not for
concern investors they they go on by
here now so when they see stuff going on
the internet saying they had a bad III
I'm willing to bet you a big portion of
the investors don't even know what they
invested in but it's true at the end of
the day like sure their stocks went down
now mm-hmm but wouldn't that Super Smash
Bros drops they sell 10 million switches
in two months that the stocks may Lee
fell due to tariffs hitting Japanese
companies so let's get a low atlas now
they let Craig bunker this cuz I know
you what do you think about this whole
thing I I think that it is not a concern
but I think you at you
I actually had an offline conversation
about it yes I think they should make a
cheaper version of the switch just from
people for Pokemon without the dog
there is own resolve a new switch
variation comes out the loss for ladies
kick I know have we got you coming up
switch topics at the roundtable always
seem to be late but yeah I was I was
saying that you know poke you with the
only reason why excuse of Pokemon
because you know what like I see you
with my niece like I would love for her
to play but there's no way in hell I'm
gonna have my niece hold my son and he's
not getting one he got a Wii U and he's
gonna love that we use like things like
look my young kids get the ship this
undestructible are you good but I think
I think there's no worry about it I
think it'll come back they just need to
just take a little bit of time and then
come back up I'm not really worried Lord
King
all out there oh no King what's going on
is they gotta make sure the pro Nintendo
talk comes out after about to troll
completely with no my troll is right now
million last you should definitely just
get afraid you should be so terrified
because all your Wii U games have run
out so yeah
you got one more Wii U game coming for
Christmas and this stock investor story
it was like yo did you pull out money
now take out money out there's no growth
there's no growth the same way I said
there and watch everybody in the
compound leave that room the vest has
got up innocence and walk away so what'd
you just say was and I'm hearing the
panic because the panic is real I heard
that back with switch for real because
you know we need to get the new crowd
and you're fine man they're fine
they got because they got warframe now
all I strip down free to play games is
here let's get it I like the fact that
the Dana junket for tonight is the data
destruct the stocks just fell out
you know when stuff is changed when a
switch topic ain't the first you're
second in the and the quotas yeah it was
waving goodbye did you play that
Wolfenstein the blurry people in this
chat SPD crap I wanna know why we don't
hear it now because the stocks is in the
bushes
I got a job I got it is don't know
excuse me it is what it is okay and I
just find that it's what's interesting
what I do agree with King is this I find
that it's interesting happened right
after the direct because I do feel there
is correlation and the correlation is
one you spent way too much to type of
time on smash right even though smash it
was most likely gonna be a success but
it's also it gave the feeling like your
cupboard may be bare right
likewise this much time you know the
fortnight thing want 16 because
obviously we all knew about this rumor
from from the longest so I think there
was a fear like you what else do you I
really have for 2018 I said I guess the
operative word fear right that's what
that's 1/2 stocks work he knows he knows
with the stock did not at the end of the
day like one thing that is interesting
as far as you know obviously people are
skeptic but the sales for the month
still was fantastic
when the MPD
over here with a little flags I
guarantee you if the if they won MPD's
this month it wouldn't say next year
2019 I would say switch one MPD's in
there the switch console as soon as well
ultimate are locked on Amazon's top 10
best sellers list hell I'm gonna have a
ribbon this is detective III
presentation
so one thing again I do agree with was
solve is that you know shareholders are
gonna panic you know it's a fear
business and like I said I'm not trying
to make an excuse for it I said lady
percent of the problem we've you know
with like really there it's the stock
market but she's like Wolfram but you go
to the bush Wolfram resolution on a
switch over under 480p no word to hold
over with before y'all be sitting here
having me eat this shovelware
for this whole time and I waited for
them to fold cuz I knew it was gonna
come wait for this topic when I saw this
topic he posted the topic in the chair
and I stay good one it's going down
I got early today we had his life book
and before we move you know obviously
you feel is nothing to concern about
obviously you know the table King we
know how he feels he feels this is run
for the hills the stocks are in the
bushes this is I think it's safe to say
the legend is the honeymoon phase you
know like with the announcements of
Pokemon you know coming in Smash stuff
like that and the fact that now the
rumor is that they're supposed to be
more transparent because the I believe
President came out and said look that's
not just there for 20
team we've got ton more stuff so now all
of a sudden is this this urgency for
transparency so to speak oh one other
stop laughing key evidence is coming
like do you think that kind of eases
that blow for the stockholders or what
you feel in it I think that seeing what
they have and trying to be more
transparent for the stockholders is
going to not really matter to them
mm-hmm I think I think it's what they're
gonna actually see and what their
decisions are gonna be because you don't
know what other companies are looking at
them at the time what's going on like
what's happening so hot you really I
really couldn't say or I really couldn't
make a decision on that
how long hop for how long was Sony stock
in the dirt it's all based on again when
you look at stockholders is all about
numbers going up and down all they care
about when it comes to money maybe this
year they brought a play when Pokemon
comes out and they're not winning MPD
went smash comes all right
no HS out now listen listen
alright still okay check this out check
this out alright I got I got something
better than so Smash Brothers the big
title right that's December alright so
I'm gonna give you all the way to
December right and you're not gonna win
December MPD's and this is what I'm
gonna tell you this I'm gonna bet you
that Hot Chip challenge I want to bet
that Hot Chip challenge they got on win
December MPD's and it shall come in
behind xbox and MPD's and and and it's
gonna be out of PlayStation in smoking
those bushes listen what I'm saying is
the conviction that I have behind the
situation I want you to have the same
conviction I want you to wave that flag
I want you to shoot those pawns in the
air out into the crowd because right now
you keep telling me that you did all
this but you know what the boss did the
boss said yo that dad that that director
we put out was an indicative of what we
got for the yet so they called him on
the phone I was like yo who the hell oh
sanction that direct I don't know what
they was happen about switching Xbox one
lifetime me on the lifetime says all you
want that's nice I know it that we you
did I know what the future holds for you
so you had a flash in the pan
it was hot for a second but you're not
now and now the time of the trolling has
begun
the troll has started I'm not ready no
smash that's just my penis is important
I'm betting on the Pokemon month they go
oh you know it's funny you know what's
funny I'm the exact opposite I'm petting
on smashing our Pokemon really Wow
because pay nothing out in December and
there's nothing but red dads out those
before the don't Joyce you might see I'm
convict on the whole joint for the year
cuz everyone wanna know why cuz Sony
addict I don't you think we're five
years into the generation you would
think most people like I gonna sell
consoles let me wrong mmm-hmm people
gonna buy consoles to play Red Dead red
that you ain't come out and old five
years has been here wow that is true
hello so let's do see the reason I've
ship I'll bet you on the chip they've
been in these segments if like I say
it's the dentist's which does not win
MPD for the remainder of the year you
take that Becky let's go cuz I was a
whole lot of this Pokemon come up I
don't know the November November I
really stay alright so I got no grumble
it will me like guys I got sovereign in
December
no games you said they're not winning
another one
I got the hose gonna win December
there's no doubt in my mind they're
winning December I'm nice confident see
anyway the only way they will not win
December is if people don't buy
Christmas gifts until December I'm
nervous about with that is that when we
drop the price I they will know you
don't listen
remember last 27 are you are you Eddie
hold on are you saying this switch is
gonna go down in price number last
year's IOP the big vending me was who
was gonna win November right I was all
we talked about and we had Tendo in the
mix yah yah yah
and it's so all I'm saying is from July
at the end of the day like you don't
even really have to worry about anything
okay spider-man comes out in September
oh why would any middle got another
knows I mean
games coming up between now I wanted to
be on exciting games I just love it Oh
[Laughter]
to the chat I know Peters like what the
hell
guys my headset I was like I turn this
back up now
Lord sob you are Odin
alright so despite my passionate rent
right now I'm usually the dude is even
keel about the models nothing really
piss me off like well when I heard okay
so recently Jade Raymond the co-founder
and the general manager of EA motive and
you guys know her from UB Montreal she
was one of the did one of the creators
of Assassin's Creed so she was talking
to Game Informer magazine and talking
about you know what they were had in the
pipeline and they have an open-world
action game adventure game that has no
name yet has no release date but they're
talking about kind of what the game is
about so then she comes out and mentions
that they have something else in the
works that they just recently whoa she
said it's in development it's full-on
development yeah let me guess what no
that never mind continue she mentions
that there's something else in the
pipeline that three developers at the at
the company came to came to like upper
management with and they talked about it
and they decided to green like this and
apparently it's also in full development
now we don't know how big this is or
whatever so my thing is when you when
you hear about more games coming from a
development so you like okay great Wow
when it comes to EA though hmm I get
pissed off because I'm like finish
something good first and I'm like yeah
this is what motive is done in the three
years since their damn baby they've done
the story mode for Battlefront 2 which
many people it was beautiful but it was
hey it was alright it was it wasn't a
great thing then they took over the
remnants of visceral and amy Hennings
game that we don't even know what that
is right that's a fact we have no idea
what that is if it's anything at all
right mm-hmm
they have something else Star Wars in
the works that we don't know what that
Star Wars thing is that the the one from
my dudes from
no respawn is separately spawning Vince
Zampella that is M Pella outdoors Anton
was working on a stone no Bioware
remember Bioware Montreal GaN absorbed
into motives did it as did visceral
right so all the stuff they were working
on is kind of shelved right and um
Bioware has said they're not going back
to Star Wars until after Anthem after
Dragon Age and after revisiting Mass
Effect again so they're not right now so
my thing is all right so let me get this
straight they're not going back to Star
Wars to Elder Scrolls 6 comes out got
you continued probably yeah till 40 like
you said right attic - you're like 40
you're not gonna see some horse again
from Bioware good I mean that's what it
is
so my thing is this they're talking
about especially with EA man EA guys you
know you have you don't look good in the
eyes of the fans right now anthem has to
come out and be a hit and to be honest I
saw the 20 minute video it looked great
it looks sharp
it looked polished but it looked like
another one of those in looking like
okay I will say one thing
mm-hmm they don't have to have the
respect to gamers when they go cashed
that check at the bank cashing the check
from write the check FIFA World Team
World Team whatever like monitors every
year they made a billion dollars that's
insane so yeah I understand that they
making the money really want like I used
to love you a games mm-hmm it's not that
way anymore and again I'm nothing I feel
sorry for a but I do I do i am fearful
for these other side yes if you look at
what happened to this role what happened
to EA Montreal
oh I was Bioware's on the ropes right
now let's keep it funny
exactly if this is not a hit it's a wrap
let's keep I feel my thing is like why
are you continuing to spread yourself
thin not even talking about what you
have
pipeline they mention you have more to
do like you haven't released really
anything of Merit oh so my thing is what
do you guys think of this cuz I like I
said I don't get pissed off by things
but talk about more stuff like no finish
what you're doing we got our first would
lost a little bit what do you think
about you a motive what's your hope they
what I'm thinking is happening is they
have a group of small people like a
small group of developers up there that
are working on a new game but they're
not talking about and they're that's
their next game while they're working on
everything else that's what I think that
they're doing they're saying it's in
development but there's like three guys
working on it in like the broom closet
let's let's just take a second and think
of what they've been putting out up
there and they had some quality stuff
but they haven't put out quality stuff
as of late they need to really focus on
what they're working on and I I really
hope that they they literally have three
guys in the Boone closet working on this
next game and they're not telling us
what it is very good the three guys with
like a chair and like a folding desk I
think you're giving them too much credit
oh thank you up man what do you think
about he a boater but I spread
themselves then is it what's going on
what you think eh trash move on
Louisville then looking well my thing is
he doesn't give a rat's about what you
buy they just made a billion dollars off
of microtransactions so what this is
know exactly that you don't know you
know what the inner-workings is one of
the game comes out if they can attach
microtransactions to it because listen
if I made a billion dollars Oh for
microtransactions over so I'm trying to
put in every game so they got right so
okay so now they're gonna find a way of
getting back because they need that
billion dollar back I don't care I will
put it I wouldn't care about the outcry
I'll put a hundred people complaining
maybe fifteen might stop the other
eighty five someone invest ten dollars
in the micro transaction just takes six
people to make up a cell at one sale
you're right and that's it and that's
the drop in the bucket for them yeah
absolutely
but and they and then this whole talk
with them about how they're they've
really at this loop Bach stuff all
they've done is figured out a shadier
way of giving it to you that's because I
like choice I like to choose if I want
to buy this horse or I'm gonna do
whatever I don't care about that part
that sounds like a broke person's
problem then you see the hard road with
that though is that they've made it
right if you put it in a game and it's
just a choice and it doesn't affect the
game purchasing or laser I'm gonna do
that about I don't know Peter said it
got three guys at broom closet I'm
pretty sure they do got three guys with
a broom closet and I'm pretty sure that
they comment on it so answer is a bust
like it's gonna be it's gonna come out
it's gonna be a buses if you saw
something that moves you to go preorder
that game
that's 15 minute trailer if you saw
something a movie
I don't know cuz I did and they're not
getting that bread all right until it's
out boots on the ground and I see what's
going on I'm not buying it cuz I got a a
pass and I'm gonna play that game first
and I'm gonna see what happens
that's the huddle thing they know they
don't need you because you pay that you
paid that third you pay literally have
fun you know what at the end of the day
it's worth most people weren't even
buying too many a game so like let's at
least get half of what a game shot the
slo-mo he said no problem
microtransactions if they are simply
cosmetic but where defects gameplays or
your overall experience like NBA 2k he's
like right this might be a little bit
off topic but I see that 2k starting to
lose lose its height man it's like I
feel like people are the life is the
live is gonna sell they drop the
discount price you know how big John is
on 2k yeah who plays it probably a
hundred hundred fifty hours LCD and I
was like he complain off for like a day
I'm just tired of doing that I get it
getting all that that man was playing
live the next day I listen I get it you
know and at the end of the day you know
it's like to me is like this never I
don't know how we can off the lot but
it's like this never anything that
Abadan MPD's come out and you see that
definitely we know that they know how to
run the company right all right we know
that I understand what what's happened
the saying you want them to focus on one
thing
put that project out stop spreading
yourself thin move on to the next
project that's what you would do if you
had common sense but we all know they
don't have that and so expecting that to
happen for
them is that's disliked active pigs to
fly that's not gonna happen
alright so we're gonna get projects
until we start voting without dollars
and it seems that we aren't because they
made a billion dollars off exactly
alright so we will continue these get
the same crap shoved about throws until
we can stop those guys from purchasing
soccer boots alright so we can have this
topic but until then they gonna keep
doing whatever they want to do and
they're gonna spread the stuff
listen when you should have known when
they told you the great game of anthem
is coming broken but nobody missing
features with people though PvP is not
an issue issue two they put sixty hours
in the games like what's this
I was raging cuz I wanted to participate
get your fairly speedy that you hear me
yeah I guess but you feel about it they
need to put some PvP into a something
because most people are gonna be like
alright
the like I would play prime example
titanfall to these backwards
I love playing just to cut the the
campaign name and then I played some PvP
and I played that for maybe a week and
then I was like all right I'm cool I'm
done but if they don't have that PvP
they're not going to hold anything mmm
that was the only way we had last week
Eric's on we all know that they're gonna
backtrack that like I guarantee you
they're going to a PvP before the second
anthem comes out I guarantee you if like
I said it's not a success out of the
joke I don't want to jump on an e/m or
things any chances are like yeah my
whole thing is just like listen I'm
feeling sob like you know I spread
themselves they're you know kind of you
know this
the devs in the closet trying to pump
stuff out at the end of the day my main
concern is just like I'm just very
concerned about studios under that
bandages die you know saying especially
my people they got two of my peoples
over there he got sent Peller and they
got Casey Hudson and if Adam doesn't
succeed that Studios going you know I'm
all but shot out to Jay Farzana
childhood donation man
you said enter them with an anthem
without PvP is a bit of a failure for
longevity sake without it the game will
get old fast awesome so that's the Fonz
man much appreciate it oh yeah so it's
like you know was in trouble please yeah
they're coming off a bad look with a
drama we're all ready he got all folded
into motive yeah is it motive right now
so it's like they got discipline you
know Casey Hudson they got the 18 you
know sit over there with anthem but
again PvP is a big concern Zampella
you know I was seeing with the titanfall
bat release date see it fiasco now I'm
hearing he's doing the Star Wars yeah I
am concerned for these studios
underneath the band the only positive
thing I feel that obviously besides like
the king saying I didn't make it money I
don't care
with those big you know the fight for
microtransactions sports seriese nor lat
but the only thing that I think really
was positive from them last year was the
way out and I believe homie number homie
at the Game Awards that was his old game
that had given him my almost triple a
budget from what I heard recently
there's room out that he's actually
gonna get you know the name charted on
the MPD so much so that's the only
positive thing that I see that they were
doing you know I'm saying aim to see
what happens with that but yeah I'm
would solve I don't like what I'm
hearing about this mode of stuff
spreading themselves thin and it's
concerning its concern I want to see
what happens and her exact words were
it's an active it's an active
development it's a full-fledged project
it's an active development you know so
she wouldn't use those words unless they
were actually really working on it and
not you know ordering it somewhere like
I'm saying that we going too hard that
we got to give anthem a chance to anthem
will be fine with our panthans trash
you know what I don't think it's gonna
have the longevity I'd rather play on a
break that anthem oh well fastback is
saying where I actually shot the Lord
Eric's who we actually repeated he said
Anthony fine because he's saying that
it's an online open world game with the
event story that we add on reckless so
maybe they're going for that Lane like
Eric's were saying where they don't try
to be the next destiny or the next
division and maybe they just go for like
Mass Effect cooperative for place you
know story driven narrative driven
experiences if they if they change that
narrative and make it and come out be
like you know what this is just a
full-fledged RPG multiplayer off the RPG
and and and take that whole wanting a
multiplayer out of the narrative maybe
it works but that's not how they
presented that game that is true that is
true I mean listen I I can see a ling
for them if they say okay you do your
co-op stuff you got the story you got
all this stuff you go away from um and
then it keep kind of coming back with
kind of destiny refresh did they
nightfalls any stuff every week right
now the what keeps destiny going is PvP
all right the story doesn't do it
alright so okay so now that we
understand that now that we understand
that they have that rage won't keep
destiny or floor alone right AB not
alright alright so now that we
understand that there's a component that
is shown to form success right that's
you cater to both ends of the crowd
because you need both ends of the crowd
to keep it afloat during the low periods
now unless you're doing a guest writer
of the week that's gonna drop a new
content every week I don't see them
putting that much money into a game as
dropping new content a new story content
into that game at that basis to keep you
in gay
I see it going stable I see maybe it
have a different branching if you use a
colossus opposed to a regular Spartan
suit or whatever the suits is called
javelin whatever the hell's right so if
you're using a different suit cater to
life like we think is a warlock hunter
Titan type of makeup right small medium
and large um and it's a different
direction for each soup alright so
you're gonna do that storyline you do
then storyline you do that storyline you
play the storyline with your friends I
don't know how much content is left in
there if they don't have guest writers
every other week even the content fresh
it's going to go stale variation what
about the Casey Hudson inform is the
Mass Effect influenced we all love Mass
Effect for the most part on this
Roundtable
like do you think not even that could
save it if they have like really strong
Oh a lot of people that's their beat
with destiny they're like yo that story
trash like I don't believe I'm saying
like so like what if this just all
storage storage story heavy and you get
invested in it sorry cancer the reason
why I don't believe that to be true is
because of what they're trying to give
us they're trying to give us an open
world situation where it's co-op right
now you're gonna say that there's gonna
be storylines that you're able to branch
off into and maybe those storylines are
deep maybe you say each story line will
probably branch off into two or three
hours right you got to think about the
engagement that you're gonna have with
your friends so they don't want to make
it too long that the guy has to leave in
the middle or something like that saying
they wanted to do it in a sense that
it's gonna be like alright maybe a half
an hour each like complete story or
whatever that you knew what your friends
to keep their engagement level high I
don't see that much content given into
these systems with with this is just too
much limitations for that for the scope
that's all one
you don't want Diablo your one Mass
Effect's your one all rolled up into one
and I don't think that this game is
bringing it across
I didn't get that from what I've saw mmm
actually I want to tell you that they
actually uh I think I message
come to Midway due Friday
they are actually starting to do live
streams of anthem and they're the first
one they're doing I think it's like once
them once a month or something like that
and I actually grabbed most of it on
Friday and they started talking about uh
the the suits you get as you level it's
not like it's not like hey I'm deciding
to pick the storm suit right with a
ranger student and that's the story and
go through when are these um these
streams I think I just happen to grab
one on Friday I'm gonna need that man I
ran at an eye core so I need something
else everyone has different ideas of
what this was supposed to be is a major
problem at the point that is just a
tunnel vision type of thing that you
know exactly what you get if one person
believes it to be one thing they don't
like that but it's not that thing they
don't purchase my widely des feel like
it's an acceptable thing to have their
game out there no one knows what it's
about like I don't like we know the
overall concept of ant but we have no
ideal other than that we know we fly
around like Iron Man and we shoot [ __ ]
that's all we know when we know it has
no PvP it's a perfect like a way West
one thing you know what that's the one
thing that everybody can agree upon yeah
what King said makes sense it's like
it's like if this is all story based
stuff you don't have something that's
short and repeatable then it's very
tough to get people engaged for hours
and hours on end to get through this
stuff so you need something in there to
kind of cleanse that palate right and he
shout out to Jay born in the UM in the
Canon because he said specifically it's
the loop and and Adam King mentioned
Diablo what is it that brings people
back to their because yeah
you you don't get a new an expansion
like once every two years or some prior
it's diluted back right so that's
something that they promise where the
loot is gonna be something that's really
and how you attain that loop and I think
you know I don't play it like you guys
do but it's for me when I was playing it
that's what brought me back like what
what new gun can I get what can I get
right I mean if it has that in spades
mm-hmm maybe I really think that like
I'm the only person I know that plays
destiny for the story in the raid in the
loot ii like the Fonz of the shed shout
out to him slow-mo also a lot of people
I've seen I'm seeing the talk of people
saying what about a Borderlands wait
didn't it was a PvE and it was a success
it was a cooperative shooter it had Lou
you're gonna mean like what about that
like what if it could like the next
quarter that's what makes I do get that
and if it's well done they can make it
work without PvP don't want this is
ether EA so I do want to put that into
consideration and to have we had a loot
shooter like Borderlands is Borderlands
2 the markets changed since Borderlands
dudes been along the concept that you
just said was Borderlands right that's
cute right Borderlands at its peak can't
touch destiny at its low you think about
it in this in that aspect of it that PvP
and Borderlands element it was a success
for Lance wasn't designed to be out for
years at a time yeah it's not this is
what I'm trying to say right I mean
because Borderlands is a good example
it's a great example actually mom of
that type of game and it has a nice
story to it if you can actually get into
story
but the loot based system of it in the
fact that it was like a million guns
right yeah I did it fear compared to the
numbers of a game that has he says
borderline Boylan's wouldn't have had
the longevity they say a destiny has or
that anthem wants he's saying I mean
it's a valley it's gonna be interesting
with anta because it I do agree I think
what's gonna set up Jonathan be still
said the same point
that's it resonates with me in a sense
that the fact that we're all agree that
we really still don't know what exactly
anthem is again hopefully we get this
information you know saying and it's
gonna come through you know with these
training what's up I missed that destiny
xxx because a moonlighters there was
triple xp for vowing be bro that's your
business
let's wrap this thing up there we go
because extra ominous so you know we
gotta got it
so let's um get into this last poll for
the week so with the rumors of next
generation consoles appearing to be
releasing much sooner than later
how do you feel about the current
generation of consoles coming to a close
the choices are a over to Seoul
current generation which was just
hitting its stride be current generation
is too underpowered bring on the next
gen of consoles or see I don't care you
don't want that smoke with the Google
Yeti there's something reason I had a
feeling it was gonna be switch related
please Rock the IOP Poe and it goes up
on Twitter tomorrow Lord PT Lord smelled
O Lord solid oak Marvin e welcome
y'all guess and actually forget all that
man a friend to the realm on the real
man these guy known him a long time
absolute pleasure to have in the iron
Lords podcast round table where can the
fine people can find you and what do you
have going on so uh you can find me at
on Twitter so now they want Twitter oh
you can find me on twitch as smell
though nobody ever has the name so it's
but uh I am on there five nights a week
at least from 70 send me his info on
Twitter please yes I got you say yeah so
uh five nights a week Monday Friday
that's what are this no doubt we got
that uh twitch stream and schedule up
and what games are you gonna be done
streaming man what's going on so uh this
week I really haven't decided yet I'm
gonna talk to get into blood-borne and
Dark Souls we need to get this or you
could be real G just jump straight in
Ania Oh what am I not allowed to use
magic like you either
one CBC bid you could tell yeah we're
gonna have to figure it out probably
gonna get to some moonlighter this to
meet you finish that up so you do all
your doing to say tell these people that
games great that game is addicting if
you are head originates the minecraft
looking one over the top with the Tommy
real quick so thank you for the donation
brother yeah I better not sleep on
octopod traveler great stream ladies and
gents thank you so much Tommy's been a
day one man put those batteries in
[Laughter]
probably do a moonlighter and probably
gonna be hitting up the division and
maybe some destiny towards the end I
literally played moonlighter all day
yesterday and all night hours just about
I played moonlighters all yesterday half
the night then I went to move my mom's
stuff and then I in straight on the
podcast when I walked in the door if
what if you want to not sleep get
Jurassic Park evolution
I literally what my wife was playing the
game I went to bed I woke up to go to
work the next day she was still playing
playing for 8 hours she's like oh my god
I can't believe it's 5 o'clock in the
morning yesterday I was like well I'm
gonna go ahead and get some sleep
so I look I was like
probably like to wish looked it's like
7:30 it's like whoa I guess I'm up the
rest today cuz I'm on the last boss and
and I'm and I walked in and then I'm
like man I'm completely not prepared for
this dude so I have to go grab like six
more males so I could beat him oh you'll
make sure your folks not on Twitter as
well shot the slo-mo he said put it now
put it I put it in ten Oh make sure you
like I said make sure you do some
division man slo-moes about that
division line finish irrelevant a lot of
these guys at division guys - man I love
the division I'm 350 hours in that I
can't stop I see you on that a minute
people party say weird old stuff and
leave you a plate of Wisconsin - what
happened this whole week the try-hards
happening the try-hard had me on a lot
I'm sorry I was booed up this whole week
are the most clever side track I've ever
seen you Dookie hilarious Lord haddock
bread with the found people find you
what you got going on you swat me on
Twitter I'm probably not constraining me
this week because of moonlighters I did
beat battle chasers that was a great
game - if you really like older final
fantasy definitely try battle chasers
the last boss had me very foot that I'm
liking like these indie games they
actually have last bosses like they
don't have like pushed off the last
bosses the indie games this year have
are just so primo it's so good I can't
even say it
yeah they don't fire that's what I
bought Tommy I got I got John to pick up
moonlighters this dude was - tip was
behind me I woke up he's exactly where I
am cold night like me and John's
probably put in a day and a half and I I
installed the game the day before
yesterday bleh
at the big bad John no doubt so that's
what's going on with attic Lord stuff
which got going on man oh yeah first of
all Matt big shout-out to Lord snow
though for coming to day one and then
you can rewatch it heavy but understand
if you introduce Jon bones Jones you
must say inducing drugs honestly I
appreciate everything you're doing with
your streams it's not every day that
somebody uses a game plan to help other
people yeah people into the gaming fold
I think that's a fantastic thing because
honestly all of us here we know how
therapeutic gaming could be and the fact
that your whole purpose for doing what
you're doing is to make sure that people
who don't have access to these games can
have access to it it's a fantastic thing
man so honestly like just keep doing
what you're doing man much appreciate it
thank you out no doubt lord King we're
gonna find who found you first
first and foremost o us now though I
like to say thank you thank you for
being part of the patreon thank you for
all that you're doing for the community
and um I will also like to say thank you
for being a willing participant and
teach stream team we're trying to get a
stream team together
Lord small though
lord l-boogie um no the team is coming
together why what we want is the best of
the brightest to roam at the IOP banner
and he represents of course well if you
didn't get a chance to hear his bio in
the beginning I would love for you guys
to listen to the show and its entirety
cuz if you came in at any point in time
what he spoke about and what he's about
should resonate with this community and
it's [ __ ] and and in building you to
empower you to try to do certain things
that that he's doing as far as giving
back to the community because he gives
back a lot and buckets and in spades
he's not just gaming for itself he's
gaming for a larger cause um you can
find me on twitter at king david OTW
where it is lit and I'm probably going
viral every other day every like every
time I make it to it you can ask Laura
cogbi no I'm like that woods going
somewhere I made one tweet that was like
the same people that were making fun of
the Scorpio and Lou or the same people
changing a name every place they should
exclusive that bet they went viral like
300 yes my tweet went so crazy about the
place
oh but how dad went so all over the
place that I got probably like like 50
me follow us that was hating me first
explain my point that was a funny day
yeah yo once again salute most
oh man huge huge guide around right now
starting a lot of positive things man
like massage say like that stuff doesn't
get the shine it is supposed to and
really support this guy out here man
he's doing a lot of stuff cash flow
streams very entertaining very thin guys
strong personnel you know we're gonna
have you back at some point you know I
mean and of course and they said we got
our paint bills you know Sam but um yeah
man shout out salute to the patreon now
this is the kind of stuff that we really
appreciate and salute to lost all for
really holding that aspect down and uh
like I said saluting the winners all the
people who won and all the people who
continue to support that really means a
lot helps the podcast grow gets us
better that the nations are definitely
appreciated as well you know me so make
sure you hit that like button all that
good stuff on arm IOP and the inner
circle media outlets links are in the
description shout out the carboxy was
gonna have that audio up later tonight
and then also flashpoint 22 was huge
already boxes please catch that we
talked about what's going on we talked
about the eight barons that helped kill
Cain all the coverage all the new stuff
coming it's a blowout information
special please make sure you guys check
that out and obviously combat talk talk
with the King it's gonna come know
that's coming soon working is that
almost I've seen stop by to seize the
day you might get that right before cuz
it's gonna be the beginning analysis of
the fight there's gonna be a live
reaction to the fight is gonna be the
post fight alright so you're gonna catch
combat talk with the King on IOP Network
and we're trying to get the Pacquiao
matisse say yes sir so yeah please make
sure you guys support that when that
goes up on aisle peach and like I said a
little flash point lot more content
stuff coming appreciate this but
everybody enjoy your Sunday if anybody
thing else got anything else to say we
out of here please